reject nation how are you I'm good how
are you great the entire reject
community when we say reject nation easy
to talk I'm just talking to John so
we've gotten so many requests over the
past 48 hours or almost 48 hours for
this and John and I haven't done it
because neither of us watch God what are
you talking about Greg I've watched all
four seasons in the show there's so much
TV we're watching her plenty of TV shows
on patreon our TV shows that we watch on
her own time to unwind and haven't made
time to watch Gotham but I haven't seen
a lot of camera Monaghan's clips of
Gotham I have friends who are obsessed
with this show and they'll be like he's
got to watch this scene you gotta watch
the scene well I haven't had a couple
disparate episodes here and there I mean
I mean for the longest time I would I
would check out stuff from flash and
arrow and I'd never watched the shows
and now I'm like watch those shows so
who knows maybe this will be the one
that finally makes me go I think I'm
gonna officially start it yeah yeah
little Bruce so this was the jerome
white band trailer Jerome the joke I
mean they call him to Rome and I'm not
even entirely sure if he's exactly Joker
or not based off of how people have
talked to me about it now he's just
gonna be really old when he finally
fights Bree yeah he's essentially the
Joker anyway enough beating around the
bush
just ready to burn it down what
Hey
[Music]
yeah
whoa whoa the Legion of horrible [ __ ] I
think I'm gonna start this show damn it
Oh looks cool yeah Wow
love that [ __ ] elevator fun music while
they have guns they do something crazy
[Music]
[Laughter]
is he gonna become bad man like I'm just
season
huh wow that's like my dream Batman
movie and all those villains coming
together yeah
thanks Gordon yeah I had like a dream
Batman there's a comic books of it we're
like the entire row gallery
we're like the big row gallery the
entire one comes together and one of my
dream yeah we're like Arkham Asylum like
that yeah and so like having a season
that has a lot of that sounds freaking
awesome well yeah and I've always loved
the Scarecrow and that alone had me
being like oh I want to check this out
yeah especially to see what they do with
that cuz they're getting better with the
effects and the set pieces on these
shows I don't think I'm gonna do
reactions to the show this is the kind
of show where I'm like I'm gonna have to
catch up to the show like 20-something
episodes per season and this is sports
season right now I think something like
that's that's just a lot but everyone
raves about this guy I don't know if
they call him the joker yet and I think
that's the thing that kind of upsets
people I really don't know I mean even
in this trailer they never refer to him
as the joker miss Jerome so really
giving the Joker an identity because
obviously the Joker if they come out and
they're like knives different guy I
think everyone's gonna be really
annoying right here and it looks like
they're they're really teasing the
buildup of him actually officially
becoming Batman I mean this is just so
off the timeline of how all other Batman
tales progress because a lot of these
villains are introduced post the birth
of Batman yeah and Bruce still ain't
that old it means no it's not I mean the
kids still definitely grown up though
you know yeah it's funny to me how the
big hype of this show is Jerome like
that's the main reason I want to check
this show out as I saw the first like
three episodes and it really wasn't my
cup of tea at least at the time when I
watched it because I watched it when it
first came out and I feel like Who I am
now and the kind of television I can
appreciate I think now I can appreciate
the show Gotham it seems like they're
villains like usually when I hear about
Gotham
about their villains because people were
freaking out before about the guy who
plays the penguin - yeah he's really
good yeah so like I'd be honestly I'd be
interested to check out at least a few
episodes on that front because the
villains are often the most interesting
and the juiciest character yeah you know
you're only as good as your villains
right I mean yeah I can make time to
watch the rest of Black Mirror narcos
get caught up on the wire finish The
Sopranos yeah you know start six feet
under so you know pile it all on I never
have time to do anything else never stop
no bathroom breaks I'm gonna get I'm
gonna build a toilet and a kitchen into
this sofa and then you never absolutely
I mean visually the show looks pretty
bomb right now from the images I got
from this trailer I was getting a lot of
joker and scarecrow like a lot of
hallucinations and stuff especially when
like Harvey and Jim are running through
whatever hallway and they're like
where's the house yeah this is a part of
their hallucination and maybe the jokes
are planted in their mind but the Joker
and scarecrow teaming up is like the
dream duo I've always wanted oh yeah
done in a movie yeah yeah and this guy
should just be the Joker and like some
future film you know he just should he
embodies it I just just these few images
alone I'm like Island I enjoy watching
him alone here and this scenes people Oh
show me more than Jared Leto's Joker SEP
well yeah I'm on the heels of less than
satisfying big screen Joker I'm sure
people are that much more psyched to
have this guy around and and you know I
was catching hints of a little Heath
Ledger a little Jack Nicholson a little
jigsaw actually from the putters of war
zone Jake yeah yeah and you know some of
them flirt like that's why I would be
especially excited to look at this to
see like what his Joker really is
distinctive yeah they're calling this
season Gotham a Dark Knight so I really
I'm wondering are they gonna be bringing
in Batman like maybe by the end of the
season where he's gonna really start
training for I don't know where the
shows at I mean I've got imagine the
pressure to establish Batman has been
huge on this show since the beginning
like even having Bruce and kid I'm still
sure they're people being like when are
you gonna get to Batman I hope they did
that Smallville thing where you never
see him in the Batsuit yeah he's just
far away shots and Bruce thing
hinting the hey I'm in some people and
then the series finale he's gonna go
train with Raza
alright well [ __ ] I'm gonna try and add
us to lists are at the show my hop
arounds and keeping people unhappy with
the fact that I haven't finished certain
show yeah I'm gonna really Wikipedia
watch the essential episode the start
where it becomes your oh yeah I gotta be
realistic about alright guys well thanks
for tuning in
subscribe notification bells you know
the drill and if you want to see TV
shows that we are currently watching we
do it was about six show six this eight
somewhere like that it shows a
recovering consecutively over at our
patreon so go check out our patron
[Music]
you